alors souvent quand je suis en soirée et
qu'on me demande ce que je fais dans la
vie et je n'ai pas vraiment envie de
parler jeudi je suis comptable
parce que si je dis mon vrai métier
c'est un peu compliqué en réalité je
suis éco aventurier c'est un métier que
j'ai inventé toutes pièces en écoutant
mon coeur et mes convictions et qu'on
passe que je souhaite est un acteur
dynamique de la protection de
l'environnement et aventurier parce que
c'est mon rêve de gamin de parcourir le
monde et de vivre le plus intensément
possible parce que la vie est courte et
elle est précieuse
lors de mes dernières éco aventure par
exemple j'ai fait 1500 km de marche
tout autour de la bretagne pour aller
rencontrer les petits bretons et les
sensibiliser à la protection de
l'environnement
et puis j'ai fait un deuxième tour de
bretagne en vélo et ensuite j'ai fait un
troisième tour de bretagne en stand up
paddle 1200 km2 paddle en 86 jours ne le
fait pas j'ai un copain il a utant faire
le tour du monde à la voile en 87 jours
et une fois ci j'ai nagé pendant 21
heures le jersey à saint malo pour crier
haut et fort si les océans moeurs
nouveau et je voulais aussi dénoncé les
500 kg de plastique qui se déversent
dans les océans chaque seconde
et comme j'en avais pas eu assez l'année
dernière j'ai fait un des triathlons les
plus longues du monde
quatre mille cinq cent cinquante
kilomètres de vélo suivie de 290 km de
nage de marseille jusqu'à monaco en
solitaire avec une planche de 25 il est
ensuite su rentrer à paris
en courant à peu près 1000 km donc je
vous avouerai que parfois quand je dors
dans un abribus sous la pluie je rêve
d'être un comptable
donc en fait c est qu laventure c'est
une excuse à c'est un outil pour moi
pour aller visiter les écoles primaires
les collèges les lycées et pourquoi pas
les écoles d'ingénieurs depuis 2007 j'ai
rencontré plus de dix mille personnes
dix mille jeunes mais c'est surtout un
combat acharné pour créer les écoles
écologique vous connaissez peut-être
nelson mandela il avait une grande
citation où il disait l'éducation est
une arme puissante pour changer le monde
et ben est ce que les écoles écologiques
peuvent être une arme puissante pour
sauvegarder notre planète
physiquement c'est impossible que
j'aille dans toutes les écoles
donc ma stratégie c'est mettre en place
une action concrète une éco actions et
ensuite on la met dans la loire en mode
scénario j'ai donc une école écologique
c'est quoi à ces cinq grands thèmes le
premier thème c'est jean claude van
damme qu en parlent le mieux j'adore
lomé dans 20 ou 30 ans il y en aura plus
j'ai toujours rêvé de citer jean claude
van damme en conférence ça c'est fait le
deuxième thème c'est la biodiversité je
vais casser un peu votre l'ambiance est
ce que vous saviez qu'on était rentré
dans la sixième extinction d'espèces et
qu'une espèce disparaît toutes les 20
minutes
ça veut dire à la fin se tait d' une
espèce aura totalement disparu en 2050
on estime qu'il y aura plus de plastique
que de poissons dans les océans
donc le troisième sujet c'est la gestion
de nos déchets et puis bien sûr après il
ya l'alimentation et l'énergie
en france on compte 60 de 1200 ans
d'établissements scolaires 12,8 millions
d'élèves vous vous rendez compte
c'est presque deux français sur 10 qui
sont à l'école
là on a un levier puissant pour
accélérer la transition écologique mais
c'est quoi une école écologique et bas
par exemple pour l'eau on pourrait
imaginer l'installation de mousseurs
hydro économes sur tous les robinets
on pourrait imaginer l'installation de
récupérateurs d'eau ou des toilettes
sèches
j'ai rencontré plusieurs écoles en
france où ils ont des toilettes sèches
ça fait énormément d'économies au niveau
de l'eau on peut aussi supprimer les
produits d'entretien chlorés ou
chimiques pour protéger l'eau et la
biodiversité au niveau de l'alimentation
il ya un très grand combat qu'il faut
qu'on gagne c'est la lutte contre le
gâchis alimentaire
souvent quand je mange avec le velez
ville d'izu a assez du carton c'est pas
bon c'est dégueulasse et la moitié est
jeté à la poubelle
donc il faut que dans les assiettes de
nos gamins à l'école ça soit de la
qualité biologique de préférence sans
pesticides et locales et puis des fois
faut tout simplement poser la question
de quelle quantité tu veux avoir dans
ton assiette quoi parce que quand je
vois des petits gamins de 6e et
dévorante troisième la louche ça fait
toujours la même taille mais c'est pas
le même appétit
je pense aussi qu'il faut ce qu'on se
pose la question sur qu'est ce qu'on met
dans votre assiette
la viande un kilo de viande rouge est ce
qu'il est ce que vous saviez qu'il
fallait quinze mille 500 litres d'eau
produire un kilo de viande rouge énorme
fracas bergen un burger sa demande 600
litres d'eau en france on exécute dans
les abattoirs
tout laisse toutes les secondes 34
animaux 34 34 34 ça fait 3 millions
d'animaux tués par jour
et moi je suis pas vegan extrémistes
mais c'est comme quelque chose qu'il
faut donc il faut dénoncer il faut
surtout qu'on se pose la question de
caisse que je mets dans mon assiette au
niveau de l'énergie
eh bien il faut qu'on isole correctement
nos écoles qu'on passe avec un
fournisseur d'énergie renouvelable on
installe des leds basse consommation
bref il ya plein de choses à faire
moi je suis pas un expert c'est juste du
bon sens pour moi et je suis convaincu
que si demain on a des écoles écologique
on l'a des campus écologique dans une
ville ça peut montrer l'exemple
et puis les générations qui passeront
dans ces écoles ont pouvoir amener
simple dans la société
et en parlant de bon sens j'ai envie de
vous présenter trois petites écoles
aventurière adèle mathilde et clémence
il fut des élèves de cm1 cm2 elles ont
calculé que dans leurs cantines
scolaires elle utilisait parents 4725
bouteilles en plastique au lieu
d'utiliser tout simplement des carafes
il y avait des bouteilles en plastique
parce que c'était plus facile à gérer
j'étais directement le coup d'oeil donc
elles sont dit ça c'est pas normal
on va installer une fontaine à eau
incroyable idée de génie incroyable et
en plus ça fait mille euros d'économies
donc aujourd'hui on est vraiment rentré
dans l'ère du tout plastique
tous les ans on vend à peu près 480
millions de bouteilles en plastique ça
fait à peu près un million toutes les
minutes
tout à l'heure on faisait un goûter on
avait quoi des gobelets en plastique ça
sera sûrement pas recyclés donc ça sera
enfoui où ça sera brûlé francs saisis
pour l'année prochaine
alors à des motifs dé clémence elles
sont allées voir la directrice
je leur école elles sont allées voir le
maire mais moi mon objectif c'est
inscrire sa dans la loi quoi ce que je
trouve trop faible du coup là elles sont
dans la salle colbert
quand vous êtes au palais bourbon à
l'assemblée nationale c'est la deuxième
porte à droite et devant il ya onze
députés bretons qui les ont écoutés et
elles ont fait une proposition de loi
qui est très simple on a imaginé une loi
qui consiste à interdire les bouteilles
en plastique d'eau plate dans les
cantines scolaires bas lorsque l'eau du
robinet est potable
super donc là on a nos députés
on a le député qui était là qu'on fait
super mais problème c'est que c'était un
travail qu'on a fait juste avant les
élections présidentielle et avant les
élections législatives
la moitié des députés ils ont disparu du
paysage
et franchement ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie pour organiser ça donc je
commençais un peu à toucher le fond à
l'époque j'avais 28 ans vivait toujours
chez ma mère je commençais vraiment à
souder mes copains mes potes avec les
histoires des copains turier avec des
histoires d'écologie savez je suis un
peu le peintre luc vs
et puis en même temps quand vous
défendez des choses comme ça vous faites
attaquer soit par des ultras activistes
soit par leyton donc je recevais souvent
des messages de personnes qui disaient
que j'avais rien compris à l'écologie
que j'étais un outil de greenwashing
pour les entreprises sachant que j'avais
toujours pas de partenaire mais la
cerise sur le gâteau c'est lorsque je
reçois des courriers ou aux menaces de
me faire un procès parce qu'on considère
que l'éco citoyenneté et emmener les
enfants à l'assemblée nationale cette
manière c'est de la propriété
intellectuelle et que donc je suis un
voleur
j'étais un peu fatigué
je me sentais très seul et j'ai fait
quelque chose d'incroyable j'ai écouté
ma maman et ma maman elle me disait
julien monte à 28 ans c'est bien tu as
fait trois tours de retard avec super
mais va chercher un travail
tu as refusé déjà un cv une vague et ta
vie quoi donc je les écoute et je veux
faire un entretien à paris et à paris je
vous retrouve dans une belle agence
événementielle parce que j'ai fait des
études dans l'événementiel et le
directeur sponsoring mais reçoit et une
faute directe
julien votre concept d'éco aventuriers
ce très intéressant ce sont des sujets
très importants
et là il enchaîne en disant vous savez
moi je suis un vendu avant j'étais au
marketing de mcdonald's le poste est
pris depuis deux semaines je voulais
juste vous dire continuer ce que vous
faites ok ma mère m'appelle dans le
travail du boulot bah non il dit
continuer désolé donc là je me remet
otiv et je me dis ok c'est ma destinée
là c'est moi en cravate ça change et je
suis à l'assemblée nationale et pourquoi
sur la scène nationale parce que j'ai
décidé de créer un groupe de réflexion
parlementaire sur les écoles écologique
je passe des mois appeler envoyer des
emails aux députés jean marcel 40 et sur
l'e40 1 à 6 qui viennent je suis content
on débat on argumente je fais venir des
ong avec moi pour avoir plus de poids
je montre une vidéo où les enfants
expliquent ce qu'ils veulent faire et à
la fin les députés indies
c'est vraiment super on va faire un
amendement d'appel sur cette proposition
un amendement d'appel c'est quoi un
amendement d'appel c'est un rajout dans
une loi dire que on vient rajouter c'est
un article supplémentaire ça veut dire
que si on n'était pas venu les voir
bah il n'aurait pas fait cette
proposition d'accord donc là déjà
première victoire mais vont-ils
respecter leur parole
une stèle le jour
où ils ont ils ont présenté ce à
l'assemblée nationale c'était le 18 mai
il n'y avait que 4 198 900
j'ai rien dit et donc nos députés
tiennent leur parole et il présente
l'idée d' adèle mathilde et clément et
donc quand on propose une loi quand un
député propose une loi il faut
absolument que le gouvernement donne son
avis et là à l'époque c'était le
ministre de l'agriculture
il doit dire favorables ou défavorables
verdict le ministre était défavorable
non halal et mathilde et clément c'est
une mauvaise idée
ok il ya plusieurs députés qui
argumentent vivement contre et il y en a
1 d'ailleurs qui demande scrutin public
c'est à dire mais en fait moi je veux
criaient mon nom mon prénom est comme
moi on note bien ce que j'ai voté quoi
et quand on gratte un peu ce député
il vient de la région de volvic
voilà vous comprenez un peu et malgré
498 absents malgré un ministre qui est
contre nous malgré un député clairement
qui défend les intérêts de ceux qui
vendent des bouteilles en plastique
qu'on victoire 71 pour 6 contre c'est un
truc de ouf on venait de faire voter
l'idée des trois gamines à l'assemblée
nationale moi je reçois un sms des
députés je comprenais pas trop début
mais quand j'ai compris je me suis mis
je suis effondrée en larmes
je pense que c'est une des plus belles
victoires dans ma vie de l'est où venait
de gagner la première bataille mais on
n'avait pas gagné la vague était trop
fort au sud
donc voilà on avait gagné la première
bataille mais pas la guerre donc en gros
un petit amendement ça donnait ça à
adopter au plus tard le 1er janvier 2020
il est mis fin à la vente et
l'utilisation de bouteilles en
plastiques dans le cadre des services de
restauration collective
mais comme vous le savez une fois qu'on
a voté à l'assemblée nationale et à la
bête ça y est attaché au sénat et on a
nos amis les sénateurs et les sénateurs
eux j'étais un peu comme le comme le
ministre il était contre donc ils ont
tout simplement fait un amendement de
suppression qu'ils ont supprimé ce qu'on
avait gagné à l'assemblée bye bye
comme ça je re pleurs ouais et et je
mesure c'était je me renseigne pas sur
quel sénateurs a fait ça et je trouve un
dessinateur et le matin même au sénat
ils défendent est l'appellation c'est
pas une blague
ils défendent l appellation chocolatines
à la plage de pains au chocolat ce n'est
pas une blague
heureusement on est dans une procédure
accélérée en repart c'est à l'assemblée
en commission les copains députés que
j'ai harcelé depuis deux ans ils ont
fait rooney mais dernière étape
on part en cmp commission mixte
paritaire 7 députés 7 sénateurs et à la
fin du vote on gagne victoire totale
mais problème c'est que nos copains les
sénateurs il y en a qui étaient pas
contents parce que les entreprises
allaient pouvoir vente de bouteilles
dans les écoles donc ils ont demandé une
vérification au conseil constitutionnel
est ce que l'idée d'aller mathilde et
clémence respect de notre constitution
ok et en avant 2018
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer qu'on a
gagné
[Applaudissements]
alors mes amis j'ai envie de me dire
quand on entend le logging aux divas et
méchant lobbystes mais le lobbying est
super cool c'est l'écho login citoyen
vive le logging pour le bien commun
vive le lobbying citoyens pour nos
forêts pour nos océans pour la santé de
nos enfants
ok vous n'avez pas besoin d'être un
expert reconnu pour vous engager pour
aller parler à vos parlementaires
auxquels parce que c'est trop important
on est tous légitimes quand on défend la
planète et je suis très heureux
aujourd'hui d'être devant vous et vous
dire oui c'est possible de faire voter
vos idées dans la loi même quand on
n'est qu' un simple citoyen car doubler
son cp et sa seconde main est-ce que
vous pouvez levez la main ceux qui
connaissent le nom de son député
1 2 3 4
wahou 4 sur à peu près 150 personnes
voilà ça montre bien déjà que l'on
connaît pas qui nous représente à
l'assemblée ou au sénat
est ce que vous savez ceux qui
connaissent le nom de son député ce
qu'ils ont voté par exemple à
l'assemblée nationale sur les herbicides
qui est très polémique le glyphosate
vous savez ce qu'ils ont voté non ça
montre bien déjà qu'on ne sait même pas
ce que votre nos propres députés donc la
première étape c'est de se renseigner
sur qui il est et quel type de société y
défend ensuite j'ai envie de dire n'ayez
pas peur de jouer sur les oppositions
politiques au début pour faire inviter à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai dit à
l'équipe rouge que dickie bleus étaient
très intéressés par mon projet et qui
récupère est un peu le truc donc les
rouges anti ben ouais c'est super
intéressant et après j'ai dit à l'équipe
rouge collective non versées l'équipe
bleue que l'équipe rouge était motivé et
c'est comme ça qu'on s'est fait inviter
à l'assemblée nationale la première fois
donc n'ayez pas peur de jouer sur les
oppositions politiques
après il faut toujours communiquer de
façon non-violente créer un contexte
positif par exemple ici à dessein vous
pourriez créer pas moins le festival des
éco campus et faire des propositions
d'amendements
vous pourriez même rédigé vous même les
amendements comme le font les
entreprises qui défendent des intérêts
économiques privés et qui sont souvent
responsables de la destruction de la
planète et le soumettre à vos députés
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on concurrence le
lobbying qui détruit la planète
et puis si vous n'arrivez pas à voir
votre député vous allez rue de
l'université
vous allez au bar le bourbon il ya
toujours des piles sont là bas le café
est un peu cher mais c'est cool quand
même donc vivre l'écolo bing citoyen
j'en étais ou à mais surtout j'ai envie
de vous dire si vous vous lancer là
dedans
n'abandonnez pas d'accord st le combat
écologique le lobbing éco citoyen c'est
un peu comme cette expédition en paddle
de 1200 km en 90 jours
il faut rester debout pour ce qui bouge
pour rester debout
il faut faire face aux éléments moi j'ai
dû faire face au vent face au courant
face à ma peur mais il faudra aussi
qu'on fasse face à nos problèmes
financiers on fasse qu'on n'y arrive pas
qu'on lâche pas qu'on continue de rami
et je conclurai sur cette photo c'est la
nage de jersey à saint malo qu'a durés
21h c'est qu'il faut que pour la
transition écologique ou même pour nos
projets personnels on se donne un cap
ambitieux on vous dira que c'est
impossible
on me l'a dit très souvent julien tu
arriveras pas faire voter une loi
aujourd'hui on le dit trop donc on vous
dira souvent c'est impossible c'est trop
long c'est trop dur pour l'écologie de
façon durable façon c'est trop tard
mais geste après geste action après
action
il est possible de dépasser l'horizon
dont je conclurai avec un seul mot
option
[Applaudissements]